and breaking news here at five o'clock a  deadly shooting in the central part of  the valley metro police are at an  apartment building on hazelwood street  right near paradise and twain that is  just north of unlv's campus madison  kimbrough already there live joining us  now with the very latest  police were called to hazelwood street  just after 4. take a look at the scene  behind me this is where a person was  shot that person died at the scene it's  unclear if it's a man or a woman at this  time or if any arrests have been made  right now again there is a lot of police  activity there aren't any major streets  blocked off just this alleyway hopefully  we will have more updates for you coming  up in the six o'clock hour reporting  live madison kimbrough live local now